Salut aujourd'hui on est samedi, c'est donc le jour du Master Class'
et jeudi je vous ai dévoilé quelleeMaster Class', j'allais faire
Il y a beaucoup de bruit, il faut quand même que vous sachiez pourquoi ! Je vous emmène avec moi
J'explique au gens pourquoi il y a du bruit chez moi.
*rire*
Laetitia: Ah oui 3 filles là, il peut y avoir que du bruit
Jeanne: ah ben c'est sûr
Fabibi: Par contre, si vous faites attention, vous reconnaissez, et ça c'est une exclue: Jeanne les cheveux pas attachés
Où est George?
*rires*
Laetitia de "Le corps la maison l'esprit" que vous avez vu dans la vidéo...
L: Et je ne m'en suis toujours pas remise de la vidéo des rubik's cube et tout je réfléchi toujours je repasse la vidéo en boucle pour essayer de comprendre. J'ai pas compris
Céline: Ben il y a moi évidemment mais on ne me présente plus puis qu'évidemment je suis une incontournable de mon salon
Fabibi : Je vais quand même essayer de parler plus fort qu'elles
parce qu’aujourd’hui c'est très important je vais vous apprendre à compter les cartes au casino pour gagner au blackjack
En tout cas, pour moins perdre au jeu du blackjack
Attention c'est pas une vidéo, non plus, pour tricher aux cartes, au jeu du blackjack
Je vois ça comme quelque chose de très intéressant
je vous le dis, je ne me tiens pas pour responsable de ce que vous allez faire de ce savoir-faire après
je vous déconseille formellement d'utiliser cette technique là dans les casinos, ne le faites pas
vous pouvez vous entraîner pour vous parce que c'est intéressant comme jeu de l'esprit
vous pouvez le faire entre amis, si c'est pas des jeux d'argent parce que les jeux d'argent sont interdits
enfin bref, vous avez bien compris, mon but ce n'est pas de vous apprendre à tricher. Mon but c'est de vous faire découvrir une technique intéressante
liée au jeu du blackjack
Là, je suis sûr de pas aller en prison.
Retour rapide sur ce qu'est le blackjack
Le blackjack, c'est un jeu de carte évidemment, on peut être plusieurs personnes contre un croupier
et les joueurs ne sont pas les uns contre les autres
En fait, les joueurs sont individuellement contre le croupier
D'ailleurs, il y a des techniques dont m'a parlé un copain qui est croupier
des ententes entre les joueurs qui jouent entre eux, qui ont une stratégie pour battre le croupier
mais c'est pas le propos d'aujourd'hui
Au blackjack on vous sert des cartes et votre but c'est d'avoir plus gros que la banque en fait
plus gros que le croupier. Le croupier, on va l'appeler la banque durant toute cette vidéo admettons
Donc vous devez avoir plus gros que la banque. Pour gagner, sur la banque
le score maximal est de 21.
21 c'est ça le blackjack
Quand vous êtes au dessus du 21, c'est que vous avez brûlé
vous avez perdu d'office
je rentre pas plus précisément dans les règles du jeu
si jamais vous les connaissez pas, vous les trouvez partout sur internet
faut savoir qu'il existe une stratégie de base très élaborée pour gagner au blackjack
C'est une stratégie qui a été améliorée d'ailleurs dans le temps
au fur et à mesure
et cette stratégie elle explique exactement quoi faire, quelle méthode adopter en fonction de toutes les situations que vous allez rencontrer au blackjack
cette stratégie, a été créée au fil des années pour que l'avantage de la maison soit proche de 0
L'avantage de la maison
c'est l'avantage du casino en fait.
Le blackjack est un des jeux qui permet d'avoir l'avantage le plus proche de 0 voir même à 0
C'est à dire que si on respecte bien cette stratégie
on ne peut quasiment pas perdre d'argent en fait
et alors pourquoi le casino gagne
Comment ça se fait qu'il se fait de l'argent
C'est surtout qu'au blackjack, comme dans n'importe quel jeu, à un moment donné on se laisse prendre par nos émotions et on ne...
on ne réfléchit plus, on est plus raisonnable
Vous savez ces jeux où l'on dit: Ah je le sens bien là,  là c'est maintenant que je vais gagner, c'est maintenant
En général, c'est surtout maintenant que vous perdez tout d'un coup
et c'est terminé
La stratégie de base, elle permet surtout de pas perdre beaucoup d'argent, voir de ne pas en perdre du tout
mais, c'est pas ça qui vous en fait gagner en réalité parce que c'est une méthode de sûreté
on parie des mises minimums et donc la seule manière d'optimiser ça
c'est de compter les cartes
Comptez les cartes c'est très mal vu, évidemment
par contre, en exercice à faire vous, pour vous derrière la caméra, chez vous
c'est forcément hyper intéressant
Dans ce master class' je vous parle du système High/Low, haut/bas
il y a d'autres systèmes comme le High up2, comme le oméga 2, il y en a beaucoup d'autres en fait
ce qui permet vraiment de compter les cartes au blackjack,
c'est que c'est un système prévisible
C'est à dire, qu'au blackjack, on va prendre un jeu de carte
et on va passer les cartes une à une, on va les distribuer etc...
et elles ne sont pas remises en jeu
donc il y a ce qu'on appelle un passé, un présent et un futur
Le passé, ce sont les cartes qui sont passée.
Le présent, c'est ce qu'il y a sur la table actuellement
Le futur, c'est tout ce qui reste
et le compte permet de prédire le futur, de savoir ce qu'il va arriver
en tout cas de pouvoir rendre la probabilité plus forte en votre faveur
dans les casinos, ou les endroits où on joue vraiment au blackjack
on utilise pas qu'un seul jeu, on en utilise plusieurs par exemple 6
et souvent pour rendre le compte un peu plus compliqué et un petit peu plus difficile
On plante une carte
comme ça, dans le milieu de tout l'ensemble des jeux
et on se dit, arriver à cette carte, on remet tout en jeu et on re-mélange tout
C'est un peu contre les compteurs, c'est pour ça qu'il est très difficile maintenant de compter dans les casinos
d'une manière favorable. Ça fait bien longtemps qu'ils ont vu les compteurs arrivaient
Ils sont pas fous non plus
Pour vous expliquez un peu plus en détails je vais vous faire voir les cartes
"Transfert"
*rires* oh, oh, le Goldorak du pauvre. Mec
J'ai l'impression d'être tout petit maintenant
Donc le système High/Low consiste à tenir un compte en permanence de ce qui est sorti dans le jeu
alors, on va pas compter les cartes, on peut pas les retenir comme ça
par contre, on peut retenir les cartes fortes passaient, les faibles passaient ou celle qui sont neutres
parce que le High/Low se découpe en 3 catégories de cartes.
Les cartes fortes ce sont les As ou les bûches
alors qu'est ce qu'une bûche aussi?
Alors, c'est du jargon de cartomane hein !
Les bûches ce sont ces cartes là
Le 10, le valet,la dame et le roi... Et l'As
Le roi, la dame, le valet et le 10 valent 10 points au blackjack et l'As ça vaut 1 ou 11
mais nous on va s'attacher au fait que l'As vaut 11
et donc la manière la plus rapide de faire un blackjack c'est d'avoir une bûche et un As
BlackJack
J'ai gagné
Je m'énerve beaucoup trop, j'ai fait tomber une carte
Il y a également les cartes neutres, ce sont les 7, les 8 et les 9
et, enfin, les petites cartes, les cartes faibles: 2, 3, 4, 5 et 6
Voilà ça, ce sont les cartes faibles
Le système High/Low est basé sur ces 3 catégories
donc retenez bien ça. Les cartes fortes valent -1
donc les As et les bûches
les cartes neutres, elles valent 0. Donc 7, 8, 9
Et les petites cartes, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, voilà je vais vous rajouter un 6
Ça, ça vaut +1
Une fois que vous savez ça... vous savez tout
Durant toute la partie, vous allez additionner les -1, les 0, les +1
Pour connaître, le compte, ce qu'on appelle le RC,
en permanence,
C'est ce RC là, c'est ce compte là, c'est ce résultat qui va vous dire si vous devez miser plus ou pas
Tout en suivant, la stratégie de base sinon ça n'a tellement d'intérêt en vrai
quoi que si
Si ça a toujours un intérêt, en fait, de connaître le compte
et de se dire je vais miser plus fortement à ce moment là
Les casinos paient 3 pour 2 aux blackjack
c'est à dire si je mise 100 et que je gagne. Je gagne 150 en fait
donc il est intéressant de parier vraiment plus fort au moment où le compte est bon.
parce que si le compte est haut
Ça veut dire que beaucoup de petites cartes sont passées
Ça veut dire qu'il reste beaucoup de bûches et d'As dans le jeu
Ça veut dire que vous avez de fortes chances de faire un BlackJack ou alors vous avez aussi de fortes chances que la banque brûle
Ça aussi c'est intéressant, c'est une manière de gagner parce que
La banque, alors ça dépend des casinos, ça dépend des pays, ça dépend des règles
Mais ça doit être annoncé à l’accueil par contre, ou devant la table
doit retirer des cartes en permanence tant qu'elle a pas dépassé un certain compte
Ok si, admettons, elle tire jusqu'à 16.
Ça veut dire que si elle est à 15, elle est obligée, La banque est obligée de prendre une autre carte
mais si vous vous savez que le compte est haut, ça veut dire qu'il reste beaucoup de grosses cartes dans le jeu
et donc, il  y a de fortes chances qu'elle brûle
Vous comprenez un petit peu le principe
pour connaitre ce compte donc, vous allez toujours additionner en permanence vos cartes
celles des autres joueurs qu'il y a sur la table
et forcément celle du croupier
Démonstration pour que ce soit un petit peu plus clair
si je retourne là, je compte 1 parce que c'est une petite,
ensuite 2 parce que c'est encore une petite
3 parce que c'est une petite
je reviens à 2 parce que là je met -1 pour celle-ci
je reviens à 1 parce que là c'est encore moins -1 pour celle-ci
Là ça ferait toujours 1 parce que c'est 0
1 parce que c'est 0
Là je reviens à 0 parce que c'est encore -1
Là, par exemple, tout ça mon compte final de tout ça c'est 0
Pas compliqué, faut juste s'entraîner
Il faut bien sûr connaitre les cartes par cœur avec les correspondances par cœur
pour les -1, +1, 0. Ça doit devenir un automatisme en fait
Que vous n'avez pas à réfléchir, parce que là autant on peut prendre son temps
autant dans une partie, vous n'avez pas du tout le temps de prendre votre temps
Ça va très vite, les cartes sont ramassées très vite
Ça va à une vitesse incroyable
Ça doit devenir des réflexes en réalité
Le raccourci, vous l'avez à force de travail
C'est juste de visualiser, de faire des déductions au lieu de compter
Je vous montre, par exemple là j'ai une 1ère main qui vaut 0
Instantanément, je vois une forte et une faible, je... ça n'existe pas en fait dans mon monde
ensuite je continue à retourner, ici j'en ai 2
J'ai vraiment un +2 parce que j'ai 2 petites
et là je retourne ça
Là celle ci pour moi elles s'annulent
on a une forte, vous les voyez bien au fait?
parce que si vous les voyez pas je fais un peu ça pour rien
Là c'est 2 là, elles s'annulent parce que j'ai une forte et une faible
Ça c'est 0 ça compte pas. Donc, en fait, sur cette table là, je ne retiens que celle ci
Je retiens que +1
Vous voyez ce que je veux vous dire un petit peu
C'est à dire que j'ai pas fait ça plus ça plus ça plus ça plus ça plus ça plus ça
J'ai fait tiens ça, ça s'annule
Ça , ça s'annule. Ça, ça compte pas. Il me reste +1
En adoptant cette méthode là, évidemment vous balayez la table comme ça d'un regard
et vous savez exactement où en est votre compte
Pour vous entraînez le plus simple c'est de prendre un jeu comme j'ai
Vous enlevez les jokers, si il y a des jokers évidemment
et vous passez les cartes comme ça une à une et vous tenez le compte
Alors après vous pouvez le faire de plus en plus rapidement
évidemment
et vous pouvez aussi vous laissez distraire
et je peux compter les cartes très très vite. D'ailleurs, si je compte jusqu'au bout les cartes
je vais arriver à 0
Non pas que je sois en train de compter mais parce qu'un jeu entier équivaut à 0 au final
il y a un équilibre parfait entre les -1, les +1 et les neutres
Vous pouvez aussi vous laissez distraire en mettant de la musique très forte
la télévision, la musique dans les oreilles, en parlant avec quelqu'un au téléphone
C'est très important d'essayer de dissocier son compte, d'une discussion
On peut discuter en comptant, puisqu’on ne compte pas vraiment
Rappelez vous comment j'ai fait
J'ai éliminer les paires.
Ou alors aussi de retourner les cartes comme ça 2 par 2
et de devoir tenir le compte, tout en maintenant comme ça un rythme
Vous pouvez le faire en alternant, vous pouvez le faire simultanément
La vrai seul méthode en fait, c'est de s'entraîner
De s’entraîner, de s’entraîner, de s’entraîner
et ça va très très vite rentrer
alors après ça devient naturel
puisqu'on parle de compter les cartes mais on les calcule pas réellement
on va pas dire que c'est un calcul compliqué de faire -1, 0 et +1
Et quand est ce qu'on mise. Ben ça dépend du RC
Plus le RC est haut, plus il est au dessus de 2-3, plus on dit que le sabot est chaud
C'est à dire que le sabot va donner des grosses cartes
On peut dire qu'à partir de 2, on peut commencer à miser un petit peu plus parce que le sabot a bien chauffé
Si le RC est faible, au contraire, c'est à dire si il est dans les nombres négatifs. Si vous avez un compte à -1, -2, -4, -6, peu importe
Ça veut dire que là, il y a beaucoup de petites cartes qui vont être à venir
Il faut miser au minimum, même mieux il faut partir de la table de jeu si c'est possible
Vous pouvez y rester si vous suivez la stratégie de base, vous jouez les mises minimums. Bon...
vous perdez pas grand chose
Et si le RC est à 0, si le compte est à 0. Ça veut dire, que le sabot est neutre. Il est complètement neutre, on ne peut rien anticiper
En fait, on est comme à une début de partie en fait, c'est la même situation, donc si vous connaissez la stratégie de base encore une fois, jouez pas ou sinon jouez les mises minimums
Vous avez juste ça à retenir, quand le compte est haut c'est que vous avez l'avantage joueur
Je vous ai donc parlé du RC, le Running Count, en fait c'est le compte qui court
en fait le compte actuel
Il y a une autre théorie, en fait, qui est sur le TC
Le compte réel.
Alors tout le monde ne l'utilise pas, mais c'est pas inintéressant à connaitre.
C'est pour ça que je vous en parle. Le RT  vous prenez votre compte actuel, le RC donc,
et vous allez le diviser par le nombre de jeux que vous estimez qui reste dans le sabot.
Si vous estimez qu'il reste une centaine de cartes, donc à peu près 2 jeux de cartes
vous allez diviser le RC par 2
C'est à dire que si votre compte, il est de 4
en RC
Si on prends le RT ça voudrait dire qu'il serait plutôt de 2
C'est une théorie intéressante qui... qui en tout cas donne des meilleurs résultats au final que le RC pur
Mais le RC est très bien aussi
Le RC seul est très efficace aussi
mais vous pouvez upgradez ça en fait,
si vous êtes bon dans le calcul mental
Si c'est pas le cas, regardez mes vidéos sur le calcul mental, je donne pleins d'astuces
Ça vous permet d'avoir un score plus parlant
Voilà c'est tout pour ce Master Class' qui était consacrer au comptage des cartes au Blackjack
encore une fois, ne faites pas de bêtises avec. N'allez pas dans les casinos pour tricher avec ça
Entraînez vous, pour vous pour votre culture personnelle, c'est intéressant bien sûr
Abonnez vous à la chaîne YouTube c'est très important
Vous pouvez aussi, en profiter pour regarder la vidéo où je suis avec Jeanne, ou celle où je suis avec Céline, ou celle où je suis avec Laetitia. Voilà
Vous les avez vu en début de vidéo. Je sais pas si on les entendra trop. Mais alors qu'est ce qu'elles parlent
J'entends parler de lifetime, de pain dérivatif, de bio
On s'éclate à la maison aujourd'hui
Abonnez vous, objectif 2500 abonnés. A 2500 abonnés, on se fait un apéro virtuel
Je pense que je vais utiliser Périscope, et on va se faire un live de quelques heures ensemble.
On va pouvoir discuter et faire des choses de mentalismes
Mais pour ça, faut qu'on soit 2500. J'ai vraiment hâte que ça arrive, je pense qu'on va passer un bon moment
Plus ça va, plus je me dis "mais en fait ça va durer 4h 5h mais  c'est pas grave ça va être cool.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et si c'est le cas pensez à la partager
ça aussi c'est important c'est ce qui fait connaitre la chaîne à tout le monde
Et rendez vous demain à 11h pour le prochain MentalVlog avec une explication de mentalisme
Ciao!